everyone thinks they can catch punts so
we're beating up with punting expert
Johnny hacker of the LA Rams to see just
how hard it really is these guys going
down cuz when it comes to catching punts
from machine after a practice there's
nobody better these youngsters done
ain't got nothing on me
I'm about to put it down right now no
calf catching all balls normally I'd
make you catch these hands but today
these hands are catching punts yeah
they're screwed well hello left go out
here in LA I'm about to catch punts from
Johnny hacker one of the greatest
special team players in the history of
the NFL you know who else has a special
team State Farm that are sponsoring this
entire season of ditch the playbook talk
about swell people let's go catch some
putts what we have here today is the
greatest punter in the history of the
NFL Johnny Hecker take the compliment I
think - is right the NBA legend tuff
juice Caron Butler and we're the
funniest people you ever gonna meet the
biggest Rams fan ever taran killam whose
house Rams house what damn right I did
not know that cheer clearly I'm not a
Rams fan how this is gonna work it's
gonna be three rounds we each get one
attempt per round and whoever has the
most catches at the end wins now to make
it fair we're all gonna get the exact
same punt from the jugs machine whoever
comes in last there is a punishment so
I'm asking you right now you have to
agree do you agree to said punishment
agreed agreed
it's gonna come down some heat don't be
afraid bruises heal yes legends are
forever
yes Oh taran killam I make sure we give
them give a little space
fair catch fair catch rules feel a lot
of pressure right now
give them the point when you're ready
or the point is out okay
max is left
[Applause]
yeah the ball into it huh one hop in
bucket Oh
when off Wednesday all right well here
Iran Iran go make your left
going back your left yeah
nothing credible now all way to get over
the senses come to me yeah yeah oh no
that's so great that's ugly
that's I went yeah we saw so once it's
not about a punishment yeah there's
three rounds Johnny hacker oh nice after
the first round Quran one Teheran one
left and he's enjoying this way too much
oh yeah you're already laughing I'm in
panic mode right now
oh yeah I'm a righty Spyro lonely kind
of guy really funny as I've known a
difference to know right here oh yeah
bro you did that way too easy
yeah that's crude oh wow
[Music]
you're right you're right fear right
oh don't break a finger that's nice that
gives me a cushion that gives out a good
ocean right yes oh oh oh you gotta get
over here I'm gonna have to do this
punishment for sure the times taking
this punishment
I have zero tough juice has one and
taran killam caught both out of nowhere
right so what are we doing here hacker
so you got a run to the spot and catch
the ball so you gotta track it on the
run this is making things a little more
difficult for someone that's Owen - it's
gonna be Dampier possibly so we'll see
how let's go - all right let's go
oh he was right there though hey Quran
the door is creaked open
you gotta get going he's gotta get going
yeah yeah yeah you eliminate the chest
that's what happens you have that safety
of the chest
it makes it tough desperate times call
for desperate measures
no diagonals die God whatever whatever
he loved most he can't can't you see
I've never wanted someone to get a punt
in the nuts so bad over text he's got it
he's got it let's go let's go so now we
got to have a punt off versus poor on
bummer
yes I should really thank all the people
who supported me on my way to get here
you know they say don't forget the
little people what does that plan how do
we want to do sudden death between me
and Quran is it one fresh off your
actual leg oh yeah yeah let's do that
I'll give you I'll give you guys an end
over end with the wind at my back so I'm
gonna go this way
oh that's what the Sun well you have
sunglasses still don't know it's only
for the look it's not for the blob
[Laughter]
that's good I'm gonna bomb the second
ball over left girl's head so it has no
chance of winning that's my strategy
all right Darren Sproles you ready
that's going no I run yeah
yes [ __ ] it let's go hacker putts it 80
yards when it's my turn
tough day at the office for left go okay
I think this is own show with you that's
sad okay so I hear we had a man just a
real just display of grit I guess at the
end of the day the actor won
yeah great job way to go left go I think
this is your whole deal and you kind of
blew it
so you feel like that don't feel good
job and let's bring out the punishment
oh please just say it to a couple times
for people that says that I have big
dumb baby hands and now I'm gonna have
to go into the road and stand in front
of cars and let them know that I have a
big baby
[Music]
what does my life become yep honk it up
crap stop beeping hey while you're
watching me on youtube
why don't you smash that subscribe
button and watch all the episodes of
ditch the playbook right here on
bleacher report